This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Okay, just gonna record. Okay. And that is producer Mark Bramhill recording himself. It is Monday, November 7th, 2016. So what's happening here? Where are you? What is going on in this tape? Uh, so I was getting ready to go to IBM's headquarters in San Jose, California. I was going to give this presentation to about 20 people.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。好的，我开始录音了。好的。那是制作人马克·布兰希尔（Mark Bramhill）在录制他自己。今天是2016年11月7日星期一。那么这里在发生什么？你在哪？这段录音里到底在搞什么鬼？呃，当时我正准备去位于加利福尼亚州圣何塞的 IBM 总部。我准备向大约20个人做这场演讲。
I am way more nervous than I thought I would be, but it's happening. So I'm just going to practice running through the little plan script I have. So tell us what this presentation is about. So I was getting ready to make a presentation for something that if it was approved, would be used by millions of people all around the world. It would change every last cell phone, tablet, and laptop all around the world. All right, I'm sold, what is it? Okay, so it was a proposal for a brand new emoji.
我比自己想象的要紧张得多，但事情已经发生了。所以我打算练习过一遍我准备好的简短发言稿。那你给我们讲讲这场演讲是关于什么的？当时我正准备为一个提案做演讲，如果这个提案获得批准，它将被全世界数以百万计的人使用。它将改变全世界的每一部手机、平板电脑和笔记本电脑。好吧，我被吸引了，这到底是什么？好吧，这是一个关于全新表情符号的提案。
You know, those little pictograms we used to text each other, the thumbs up, the woman dancing, or the little yellow faces, that smile or wink or they wear sunglasses. Okay, I know what an emoji is, Mark G, so I'm not that old Okay, okay, you can do this you can do this You sound so nervous. I know it's really really embarrassing
你知道的，就是那些我们用来发短信的小象形符号，大拇指、跳舞的女人，或者那些会微笑、眨眼、戴着太阳镜的小黄脸。好吧，我知道什么是表情符号，老马克，我还没那么老。好吧，好吧，你能行的，你能行的。听起来你太紧张了。我知道，这真的非常非常尴尬。
Okay, I'll let you know how it goes Okay, so before you tell us what your emoji was and what they got approved, I feel like we should start with something like... Why am I doing this whole thing? Exactly. Why are you doing this whole thing? Right, so creating an emoji, it was not something that I actually planned on doing. But you do cover this stuff. You have a podcast called Welcome to Macintosh.
好吧，回头我再告诉你进展如何。好吧，在你告诉我们你的表情符号是什么以及它们是如何获得批准之前，我觉得我们应该从类似这样的问题开始……我为什么要搞这一出？没错。你为什么要做这一切？对吧，所以创作一个表情符号，其实并不是我原本计划要做的事情。但你确实报道过这些内容。你有一个名为《欢迎来到麦金塔》（Welcome to Macintosh）的播客。
You cover things like the intersection of tech and culture, and so this seems to be part of your beat. Exactly. And, you know, I think emoji, they're kind of right at that intersection. They've become this really interesting part of the way that we communicate. They're this kind of universally spoken language of pictures. But going into all this, I didn't really know that much about emoji. So I reached out to Jeremy Burge. He's the creator of Emojapedia.
你报道科技与文化交汇之类的事，所以这似乎在你的报道范围内。没错。而且，你知道，我认为表情符号恰好处于那个交汇点上。它们已经成为我们交流方式中一个非常有趣的部分。它们是一种由图片构成的、普遍使用的语言。但在这一切开始之前，我对表情符号其实并不是很了解。所以我联系了杰瑞米·伯奇（Jeremy Burge）。他是 Emojipedia（表情符号百科）的创始人。
My job is keeping on top of any new emojis and sort of documenting how they change over time. So for a real quick sort of history lesson on emoji, they started in Japan in the 90s. The first set of emojis was designed for a Japanese cell phone company by this guy named Shikotaka Kurita in 1998. When texting was still really new, there was only 176 of them, and they were 12 by 12 pixels each.
我的工作就是紧跟任何新表情符号的潮流，并对它们随时间的变化进行记录。因此，如果要对表情符号进行一次非常快速的简短历史课，它们始于90年代的日本。第一套表情符号是由一个名叫栗田穣崇（Shigetaka Kurita）的人在1998年为一家日本手机公司设计的。当时发短信还是一件很新奇的事情，总共只有176个表情符号，每个都是12乘12像素。
So that's really low res for an emoji, that's super low res? Yeah, but these were like the first images that could be sent via text message before photos or anything like that. If you see the Japanese ones, they've borderline no resemblance to what we see today. They're sort of very basic abstract pixel art.
所以对于表情符号来说，那个分辨率真的很低，超级低吗？是的，但这些是可以通过短信发送的第一批图像，在照片或类似的东西出现之前。如果你看到日本的那些表情符号，它们几乎和我们今天看到的没有任何相似之处。它们有点像非常基础的抽象像素艺术。
So these super low res emojis became really popular in Japan. And quickly, almost all Japanese text messages became dotted with these cute little pictures. But they were still only available on Japanese cell phones. And depending on which carrier people in Japan were using, these emojis could be different from phone to phone. I might send you the hamburger and you might get the poo. That's a problem.
因此，这些超低分辨率的表情符号在日本变得非常受欢迎。很快，几乎所有的日本短信里都点缀着这些可爱的小图片。但它们当时仍然只在日本手机上可用。而且根据日本人们使用的运营商不同，这些表情符号在不同的手机之间可能会有所不同。我可能会发给你一个汉堡，而你收到的却是一团大便。这就是个问题。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It seems like in our modern world of computers, this should not be happening. Right, but the reason that this was happening was that when different cell carriers in Japan added these images for their customers, they encoded them differently. So let me take it just a minute
对，对，对。在我们这个现代电脑世界里，这种事本不该发生。没错，但发生这种情况的原因是，当日本不同的移动运营商为客户添加这些图像时，它们对这些图像的编码方式不同。所以请允许我花一分钟时间来解释一下什么是字符编码。
to explain what a character encoding is. This is Mark Davis. Every time you see a character on the screen, on your mobile or laptop, it's always represented internally by a number. So there's some number associated with the letter A. So the problem in Japan was that the companies weren't coordinating about what emojis were assigned to what number. So one company might have the hamburger encoded as 46,790, while another carrier would have the poo encoded as 46,790.
这是马克·戴维斯（Mark Davis）。每次你在手机或笔记本电脑屏幕上看到一个字符时，它在内部总是用一个数字来表示。因此，总有一些数字与字母 A 相关联。所以日本的问题在于，各公司并没有就哪个表情符号被分配到哪个数字进行协调。因此，一家公司可能将汉堡编码为46,790，而另一家运营商可能将大便编码为46,790。
So when American cell phone companies decided that they wanted to enter the Japanese market, they knew that they needed the coding for these emojis to become standardized, and they turned to Mark and his organization, a group called the Unicode Consortium. I'm the president of Unicode Consortium. We're people behind the curtains making sure that everything works, kind of like plumbers.
因此，当美国手机公司决定进入日本市场时，他们知道需要将这些表情符号的编码标准化，于是他们求助于马克和他的组织——一个名为统一码联盟（Unicode Consortium）的团体。我是统一码联盟的主席。我们是幕后的工作人员，确保一切正常运行，有点像水管工。
You know, you don't notice them as long as the water keeps flowing. They're doing the 99% invisible work of the internet, if you will. I guess I'll allow it. So the Unicode Consortium had already been working on standardization for a while. Not with emoji, but with text. The consortium was founded back in the early days of the internet when there was no universal standard for encoding text or anything else you saw online. People at the time were really used to getting emails
你知道的，只要水一直在流，你就不会注意到他们。可以说，他们在做互联网上99%看不见的工作。我想我认可这种说法。所以统一码联盟此前已经致力于标准化工作有一段时间了。不是针对表情符号，而是针对文本。该联盟早在互联网早期就成立了，当时网络上并没有关于编码文本或你在网上看到的任何其他内容的通用标准。当时的人们非常习惯于收发电子邮件，
or looking at websites and they would see just jumbled up garbage on the screen because it was the wrong encoding. The internet used to be so ugly. Like when you were a baby, you don't even know. The internet was terrible then. Yeah, I have heard stories. Like, you know, Unicode, they were founded to help with that. Most of their work has to do with
或者浏览网页，结果屏幕上看到的却只是一堆乱码，因为编码错误。过去的互联网曾经是那么丑陋。就像你出生的时候一样，你甚至都不知道。那时的互联网太糟糕了。是的，我听说过一些故事。比如，你知道的，统一码的成立就是为了帮助解决这个问题。他们的大部分工作都与
language, you know, making sure that even little-known languages are legible across different websites and platforms. That seems totally fair. That make the worldwide, worldwide. Make sure everyone can be represented. Exactly. And ultimately Unicode became the B all and all text encoding standard. So since people were already relying on Unicode to standardize text encoding They thought well, why don't we get these guys to do emojis for us to yes Yes, yes precisely though when Unicode was first approached about emojis in the early 2000s They weren't interested. They thought that these cute little pictures They're probably a passing fad. I think we were all kind of hoping and praying for that too.
语言有关，你知道的，确保即使是鲜为人知的语言也能在不同的网站和平台上清晰可读。这听起来完全合情合理。这使得全球化、全球化得以实现。确保每个人都能被代表。没错。最终，统一码成为了终极的文本编码标准。既然人们已经依赖统一码来标准化文本编码，他们就会想，好吧，为什么我们不让这些家伙也帮我们做表情符号呢？对，对，对，确实如此。不过，在2000年代初，当人们第一次就表情符号接触统一码时，他们并不感兴趣。他们认为这些可爱的小图片可能只是一阵转瞬即逝的风潮。我想我们当时也都在某种程度上对此抱有希望并默默祈祷。
No, Robin. No, emojis are here to stay. And five years later, around 2006, Unicode realized emojis were not going anywhere. So they decided to take on the project of standardizing them. So they looked at all the different emojis that have been created by the Japanese carriers and sorted through them to establish an initial core library. So what was in that original set of emojis? It was kind of a hodgepodge, you know, two camels, four mailboxes, five trains.
不，罗宾。不，表情符号将长期存在。五年后，大约在2006年，统一码意识到表情符号不会消失。于是他们决定承担将表情符号标准化的项目。因此，他们查看了日本运营商创建的所有不同表情符号，并对它们进行分类，以建立一个最初的核心库。那么，最初的那套表情符号里都有什么？那真是一个大杂烩，你知道的，两头骆驼、四个邮箱、五列火车。
We need two camels because you got the one hump and the two hump. Yeah, it's really important. And so once they had that core library, Unicode decided that all additional emojis should be considered very carefully and voted on and approved by Davis and the rest of the consortium. No more two camels slipping through the cracks. Each emoji that we encode, we really have to think,
我们需要两头骆驼，因为你有一个驼峰的和两个驼峰的。是的，这真的很重要。因此，一旦他们有了核心库，统一码就决定，所有后续的表情符号都应该经过非常仔细的考虑，并由戴维斯和联盟的其他成员投票表决和批准。再也没有两头骆驼能浑水摸鱼了。我们编码的每一个表情符号，我们真的都必须考虑，
does this sort of break new ground? Does it go in a new direction? Is it going to be extremely popular? Because we know that faces, for example, are very popular. You know, the hearts are very popular and so on. So we try to weigh all these factors when we pick a set. So these guys really do pick all the emojis that are on my phone, that they are the ones who decide.
这是否开辟了某种新的领域？它是否朝着一个新的方向发展？它会变得极其受欢迎吗？因为我们知道，例如脸部表情就非常受欢迎。你知道的，爱心也非常受欢迎，等等。所以在我们挑选一套表情符号时，我们会权衡所有这些因素。所以这些家伙真的挑选了我手机上的所有表情符号，他们才是做决定的人。
Yeah, yeah, exactly. So four times a year, Unicode meets to consider all the proposals they have for new emojis, and they are the final say in which ones are approved. And once an emoji is approved, it never goes away. Emoji can only be added. Once an emoji always an emoji, you know? And so who comes up with these new ideas for emojis? Like who gets to submit proposals?
是的，是的，完全正确。因此，统一码每年召开四次会议，审议他们收到的关于新表情符号的所有提案，他们对哪些提案获得批准具有最终决定权。一旦一个表情符号获得批准，它就永远不会消失。表情符号只能增加。一旦成为表情符号，就永远是表情符号，你知道吗？那么，谁来想出这些关于表情符号的新点子呢？比如谁有资格提交提案？
So I had this question too. And I asked Jeremy, the guy from Emojapedia, and this is what turned this story from idol curiosity into a year-long journey for the proposals. Like, who is actually responsible for bringing these emojis into the world? Literally anybody, anyone on the planet, you could send a proposal in right now, and Unicode would look at it, and there's a chance that it could become an actual emoji.
我也曾有过这个疑问。我去问了 Emojipedia 的杰瑞米，正是这一点，让这个故事从一时好奇变成了长达一年的提案之旅。那么，究竟是谁负责将这些表情符号带到这个世界上来的？字面意思上的任何人，地球上的任何人，你现在就可以提交一份提案，统一码会审阅它，它就有可能成为一个真正的表情符号。
So, like, I could do this. Like, I could send a proposal in. Yes. So, of course, when Jeremy told me that, I knew that I had to submit a proposal for an emoji. Of course. Yeah, of course. What better way to understand the process than to go through it myself? But I didn't really have an idea for what I wanted to propose.
所以，也就是说我也可以这么做。也就是说我可以提交一份提案。是的。所以，当杰瑞米告诉我这一点时，我当然知道我必须提交一份表情符号的提案。理所当然。是的，理所当然。有什么比亲自经历这个过程更好的方式来理解它呢？但我其实并没有想好我到底想提议什么。
So Jeremy gave me a few basic guidelines to think about. You should be trying to prove there's already demand before you got involved. Don't start a petition and generate demand. He said that Unicode wants people writing proposals to cite evidence of demand, like hashtag usage on Twitter or Instagram, or Google search trends. He also said that my proposed emoji should be visually distinctive. If it looks the same as something else, it doesn't matter if it means something different, emojis about what they look like.
于是杰瑞米给了我一些需要思考的基本准则。在你参与之前，你应该先证明已经存在需求。不要去发起请愿来制造需求。他说，统一码希望撰写提案的人引用需求证据，比如推特或 Instagram 上的标签使用情况，或是谷歌搜索趋势。他还说，我提议的表情符号应该具有独特的视觉辨识度。如果它看起来和别的东西一样，那么即使它的含义不同也没有关系，表情符号关乎的是它们看起来是什么样子的。
But it can't be too specific, like it can't be for this one really specific kind of dinosaur or whatever. And at the opposite end of the spectrum, it can't be too vague. You know, if your emoji was just dinosaur, you might need more specificity, like T-Rex. Well, it's a pretty fine line, but I think I get it. Okay. Another thing, they don't want to add an emoji that's potentially just a fad. Right, I get that. Okay, another thing, they don't want to add an emoji that's potentially just a fad. Right, I get that. So you don't want an emoji of like a,
但它又不能太具体，比如它不能针对某种非常具体的恐龙之类的。而在光谱的另一端，它又不能太模糊。你知道的，如果你的表情符号仅仅是“恐龙”，你可能需要更具体的指向，比如“霸王龙”。好吧，这界限挺微妙的，但我想我懂了。好的。还有一件事，他们不想添加一个可能只是一阵风潮的表情符号。没错，我懂的。好的。还有一件事，他们不想添加一个可能只是一阵风潮的表情符号。没错，我懂的。所以你不会想要一个像……
I don't like a fidget spinner or something like that. Yeah, yeah, exactly. fidget spinners, who knows how long those will be around. You also can't submit logos or brands, specific people, deities, et cetera. Superman and Batman, Starbucks, and those are just not going to be included. They have to be generic. So they're already like a few thousand emojis, right? There's 2,666 as a recording, but there you go.
我不想要指尖陀螺（fidget spinner）或类似的东西。对，对， exatamente。指尖陀螺，谁知道它们能流行多久呢。你也不能提交标志或品牌、特定人物、神明等等。超人和蝙蝠侠、星巴克，这些都是不会被收录的。它们必须是通用的。所以现在已经有几千个表情符号了，对吧？录音时有2,666个，但就是这样。
So if you're not going to do Batman and Superman, what doesn't exist yet that you could actually propose? So I actually asked Jeremy this, what do people really really want? And this is what he told me. So there is a yoga, because it's a popular activity that a lot of people around the world do. And if somebody decided to submit yoga and are meditating, I think that would be quite the winner. So I'll be honest, I had never done yoga.
所以如果你不打算做蝙蝠侠和超人，那现在还有什么不存在的东西是你真正可以提议的呢？所以我真的问了杰瑞米这个问题，人们真正、真正想要的是什么？这就是他告诉我的。所以有一个瑜伽，因为它是一项很受欢迎的活动，世界上很多人都在做。如果有人决定提交瑜伽和冥想，我认为那绝对会是个赢家。所以老实说，我从未练过瑜伽。
I had never meditated. I had never meditated. I don't have particularly strong feelings about either one. But, I wanted to pitch an emoji, and this had good odds of being approved. So, Nama Steyma. Yeah, yeah, I went full Nama Stey on this. Started doing all kinds of research about yoga and meditation. Did you know, for example, Roman, that there are 35 million Instagram posts with hashtag yoga compared to hashtag running's Paltry 31 million?
我从未冥想过。我从没冥想过。我对这两者都没有特别强烈的感觉。但是，我想推出一个表情符号，而这个表情符号被批准的几率很高。所以，合十礼（Namaste）。是的，是的，我在这一点上完全进入了合十礼的状态。开始对瑜伽和冥想进行各种研究。罗曼，你知道吗，例如，Instagram 上带有#瑜伽标签的帖子有3500万条，而#跑步标签只有区区3100万条？
Well, clearly that means there has to be an emoji for yoga. Right. What would you use to represent that? So I actually decided to go with an image that I felt represented both meditation and yoga, a person in lotus pose. And that's the one where you said cross-legged and you have your hands face up on each knee, right? Yeah, yeah, exactly. The sort of famous cross-legged sitting pose, yeah. And so I found some clip art on the internet to illustrate what the emoji might look like.
嗯，很明显，这意味着必须有一个代表瑜伽的表情符号。没错。你会用什么来代表它呢？所以我实际上决定使用一个我觉得既能代表冥想又能代表瑜伽的形象：一个处于莲花坐姿的人。这就是你说的盘腿坐着，双手手心朝上放在每个膝盖上的那个，对吧？对，对，完全正确。那种著名的盘腿而坐的姿势，是的。于是我在网上找了一些剪贴画来阐述这个表情符号可能的样子。
And in the end, I put together this eight-page proposal to submit to Unicode. I felt pretty good about it, but I wanted to run it by someone who had actually gone through the process. My name is Jennifer E. Lee and I successfully proposed a dumpling emoji. Her middle name is actually the number eight, which is so cool. And she was actually in an episode that we did about fortune cookies and a while back. Yeah, and she actually successfully made a fortune cookie emoji as well. Anyway, back in 2015, when Lee was working on getting the dumpling emoji
最后，我整理了这份八页的提案提交给统一码。我对它感觉挺好的，但我想把它拿给一个真正经历过这个过程的人过目。我叫李珍妮弗（Jennifer E. Lee），我成功地为饺子表情符号提交了提案。她的中间名其实就是数字八，这太酷了。而且她还参加过我们之前制作的关于幸运饼干的一集节目。是的，她实际上也成功制作了一个幸运饼干表情符号。无论如何，早在2015年，当李正在努力争取将饺子表情符号
added into Unicode, she learns that Unicode is this non-profit, but it is controlled by a small handful of tech companies. You know, at that point, had 11 full voting members, I paid $18,000 a year to vote. So over those 11, eight of them were US multinational tech company. So it's Oracle, IBM, Google, Apple, Facebook, Yahoo, Microsoft, and Adobe. So there's really eight of the other three. They were the German software company SAP, the Chinese telecom company Huawei and the government of Oman. Did, and the government of Oman. Did she say the government of Oman?
加入统一码时，她了解到统一码是一个非营利组织，但它是由少数几家科技公司控制的。你知道，当时它有11个完整投票成员，我每年支付18,000美元才能获得投票权。在这11个成员中，有8个是美国的跨国科技公司。它们是甲骨文（Oracle）、IBM、谷歌、苹果、脸书、雅虎、微软和Adobe。所以实际上是8个加上其他3个。它们是德国软件公司SAP、中国电信公司华为以及阿曼政府。等一下，还有阿曼政府？她说的是阿曼政府吗？
Yeah, because remember, most of what Unicode does has nothing to do with emoji and mostly to do with encoding language on the internet. So the government of Oman is there to advocate for greater Arabic language support on computers. Oh, that makes total sense. Yeah. And now Lee is a part of the emoji subcommittee with Unicode. She can't vote on which emoji get approved, but she is able to help novices like myself navigate
是的，因为记住，统一码所做的大部分工作都与表情符号无关，主要是在互联网上对语言进行编码。所以阿曼政府在那里是为了倡导在计算机上提供更多对阿拉伯语的支持。哦，这就完全说得通了。是的。现在李已经是统一码表情符号小组委员会的成员了。她不能对哪些表情符号获批进行投票，但她能够帮助像我这样初来乍到的新手们
the difficult path to emoji land. So I showed her my proposal. It looks pretty solid. Yes. But I think your emoji characters are a little bit ugly. No. Well, you did use clip art. That's fair, fair.
顺利通过通往表情符号之乡的艰难道路。于是我把我的提案给她看。看起来相当扎实。是的。但我觉得你的表情符号字符有点丑。不会吧。好吧，你确实用了剪贴画。这倒也是，这倒也是。
Probably not the standard of emoji characters, so I don't know where you got them, but you might do them in more of either the Apple style or more of the Google style. She was right. My design was not great. So I ditched these clip art images and hired a professional, a woman named Affie Messer, just so that my case would be stronger. And Unicode would have a better
可能达不到表情符号字符的标准，所以我不知道你是从哪弄来的，但你或许可以把它们做得更偏向苹果风格一点，或者更偏向谷歌风格一点。她说得对。我的设计确实不怎么样。所以我抛弃了这些剪贴画，雇佣了一位专业人士，一个名叫阿菲·梅瑟（Affie Messer）的女性，这样我的理由就会更充分。而且统一码也能更好地
idea of what this emoji could look like. I polished up my proposal, named it Person Meditating, and submitted it right at the deadline. And then a few weeks later. So I'm just coming into the studio now. I just got an email from Unicode. Let's see, let me load it up. It says, the emoji subcommittee has decided to forward your proposal to the UTC. The document number will be L2-16-279 regards UTC.
了解这个表情符号可能长什么样。我完善了我的提案，将其命名为“冥想的人”（Person Meditating），并在截止日期前准时提交了。然后几周后。我现在刚走进录音室。我刚刚收到一封来自统一码的电子邮件。来看看，让我打开它。上面写着：“表情符号小组委员会已决定将您的提案转交给 UTC（统一码技术委员会）。文件编号将是 L2-16-279，致礼，UTC。”
Alright! Alright, that's it! Woo! So that sounds like good news, but what does that actually mean? It basically means that I got through the first round, that Unicode was going to hold an official vote on my emoji. And at this point, you know, you can sit back and see what happens, or if you are extra excited, like I was,
太棒了！太好了，就是这样！呜呼！听起来是个好消息，但这到底意味着什么呢？这基本上意味着我通过了第一轮，统一码将对我的表情符号进行正式投票。此时此刻，你知道的，你可以高高挂起，静观其变；或者如果你特别兴奋，就像我当时那样，
you can actually show up to a quarterly meeting of the Unicode Technical Committee and present your proposal in real life. And so that brings us back to you being super nervous before your presentation, back in November. Right. Okay. Pfft. Pff November. Right. OK.
你可以亲自出席统一码技术委员会的季度会议，在现实生活中陈述你的提案。这就让我们回到了你当年11月演讲前超级紧张的状态。没错。好吧。噗。噗，11月。没错。好的。
It is Monday, November 7, 2016. And today is the day that I'm presenting to the Unicode Technical Committee. But before we get to that, I want to talk about someone I met while I was there in the Bay Area. She was also there to make a presentation to Unicode. Her name is Raeuf Alumati. My name is Raeuf Alumati. I'm 15 years old. She's 15 years old like in high school and she wrote up one of these proposals like you did.
今天是2016年11月7日星期一。今天是我向统一码技术委员会做陈述的日子。但在我们谈到那个之前，我想聊聊我在湾区时遇到的一个人。她也是去向统一码做陈述的。她叫拉乌夫·阿鲁马蒂（Raeuf Alumati）。我叫拉乌夫·阿鲁马蒂。我15岁。她15岁，就像上高中的年纪，她像你一样写了一份这样的提案。
Yeah, and believe me, this is no small task. I've never written any proposals whatsoever. The closest thing I've done were a lot of reports in science glass. But for Reeve, this whole thing just had a totally different level of importance. You mean that some people do this not just to make a cool radio story out of it? Well, yeah, you know, because emoji is represent culture. And just like it matters to see a representation of your culture in television or movies, seeing yourself in an emoji can feel important in the same way.
是的，相信我，这绝非易事。我以前从来没写过任何提案。我做过最接近的事就是在科学课上写过很多报告。但对里夫（Reeuf）来说，整件事情有着完全不同层面的重要性。你的意思是有些人做这件事不仅仅是为了把它变成一个酷炫的广播故事？嗯，是的，你知道的，因为表情符号代表着文化。就像在电视或电影中看到对你文化的展现很重要一样，在表情符号中看到自己也以同样的方式显得至关重要。
I mean, humans all over the world sense something like six billion of these little things to each other every day. Totally, they're everywhere. Yeah, and so in the last five years, Unicode has tried to represent more people by adding characters with a range of different skin tones. They've added some gay characters and a few gender-neutral and
我的意思是，全世界的人类每天互相发送大约60亿个这样的小东西。完全正确，它们无处不在。是的，所以在过去的五年里，统一码试图通过添加具有各种不同肤色的字符来代表更多的人。他们添加了一些同性恋字符，以及一些中性色和
drogenous ones as well. But there was still no one that looked like Reooth because she wears a hijab. I felt like, you know, it would be nice for me to see, have an emoji of myself on the keyboards that I could use. Reooth felt like her emoji would help other women who wear her jobs feel more represented in mainstream culture. Even though it is something small, I think it will, you know, just normalize the hijab.
雌雄同体的字符。但仍然没有一个长得像里夫那样的人，因为她戴着头巾。我觉得，你知道的，如果能在键盘上看到一个代表我自己的表情符号，并且能够使用它，那会很棒。里夫觉得她的表情符号将有助于让其他戴头巾的女性在主流文化中感到更有代表性。尽管这是一件小事，但我认为它会，你知道的，只是让头巾变得日常化。
You'll definitely be definitely be the coolest, like coolest kid that I've ever had. I'd, I like if it does pass, I just told my friends we're good, I have to celebrate, like I'm gonna bring cupcakes of the emoji to school for everybody, even for the teachers. Cause it'd be something so amazing if hopefully it does pass. Well now I'm totally rooting for you.
你绝对会成为最酷的，就像我见过的最酷的孩子一样。我，我希望它能通过，我刚告诉我的朋友们我们准备好了，我得庆祝一下，我要带印有这个表情符号的纸杯蛋糕到学校分给每个人，甚至包括老师。因为如果它真的能通过的话，那将是一件非常了不起的事情。现在我完全在为你加油了。
They can choose more than one robot. You can root for us both. Yeah, but if it's between you and her, it's definitely her. Okay, that's fair. That's fair. So Reu and I were both presenting to Unicode on the same day. Are we presenting it, too? I'm presenting it at 1130.
他们可以选不止一个机器人。你可以为我们俩加油。好吧，但如果必须在我和她之间选一个，那绝对是她。好吧，这很公平。这很公平。所以里夫和我都在同一天向统一码做陈述。我们在陈述它吗？我是11点30分陈述。
Okay, so I'll just shoot that. Yeah, yeah. When it was my turn, they made me turn off my microphone. So, I don't have tape of what I said. But basically, I gave a little spiel about why the world was in dire need of a yoga emoji. I got a few laughs, some nodding heads. It lasted about five minutes, and then I took a few questions. After it was over, I stood there, kind of waiting for some indication of whether, you know,
好吧，那我得去拍那个。好的，好的。轮到我的时候，他们让我关掉了麦克风。所以，我没有我当时发言的录音。但基本上，我发表了一番慷慨激昂的陈述，解释了为什么世界迫切需要一个瑜伽表情符号。我引来了一些笑声，一些点头。整个过程持续了大约五分钟，然后我回答了几个问题。结束之后，我站在那里，有点在等待某种迹象，看看，你知道的，
the committee liked it. And did they like it? They wouldn't say. I finally suddenly told me, basically, you need to leave so we can vote. So I left and I just figured that they'd be in touch soon. Okay. Yeah. So if your emoji is approved, then what happens next?
委员会是否喜欢它。那他们喜欢吗？他们不说。我终于突然被告知，基本上，你需要离开，好让我们进行投票。所以我离开了，我想他们很快就会联系我的。好吧。是的。那么，如果你的表情符号获批了，接下来会发生什么？
So even though I submitted this really beautiful visual for my person meditating emoji, it's really more just to demonstrate what it could look like. And ultimately, if the emojis approved Google and Facebook and Apple and all the other platforms will get to decide what exactly person meditating looks like in their own platform style. So I talked to someone from Google about this.
所以，尽管我为我的“冥想的人”表情符号提交了一个非常漂亮的视觉稿，但这其实更多只是为了展示它可能长什么样。归根结底，如果这个表情符号获批，谷歌、脸书、苹果和所有其他平台将自行决定“冥想的人”在它们各自的平台风格中究竟长什么样。所以我为此跟谷歌的一个人聊过。
My name's Rachel Bean. I'm a creative director at Google on the material design team. But she has another title too. Oh, yes. I am also funnily enough, the creative director of emoji at Google. Once Rachel Bean and her team get the list of new emojis and their codes from Unicode, they'll
我叫雷切尔·宾（Rachel Bean）。我是谷歌材料设计（material design）团队的创意总监。但她还有另一个头衔。哦，是的。说来搞笑，我同时也是谷歌表情符号的创意总监。一旦雷切尔·宾和她的团队从统一码那里拿到新表情符号及其代码的列表，他们就会
design the images to be used on all of Google's Android phones. And what kind of guidance do they get from Unicode about how to draw them, how to make them look? Right, so they don't actually give them all that much. They give them the name of the emoji and a few keywords of things it might represent. You know, occasionally they might give a little bit of guidance of, you know, the bagel emoji, it should be drawn sliced so that people won't confuse it with the donut.
设计出将在谷歌所有安卓手机上使用的图像。那么他们从统一码那里得到关于如何绘制它们、如何让它们看起来像什么的指导是什么样的呢？是的，实际上他们并没有给出太多的指导。他们给他们提供表情符号的名字以及一些可能代表它的关键词。你知道，偶尔他们可能会给一点点指引，比如，百吉饼（bagel）表情符号应该画成切开的形状，这样人们就不会把它和甜甜圈混淆了。
Right. So that makes it so that Google emojis look different from Apple emojis and they look different from Twitter emojis. They're all really different. Exactly. Characters might be facing in a different direction or have different outfits on
没错。所以这就使得谷歌的表情符号看起来与苹果的表情符号不同，它们看起来也与推特的表情符号不同。它们真的完全不同。没错。字符的面朝方向可能不同，或者穿着不同的服装，
or maybe dance in another style, but they should all illustrate the same basic concept. And recently, Rachel being an entertainment Google have redesigned the entire library of Android emojis. For all the emojis that weren't just disembodied faces, the team had to deeply consider all the clothing and accessories that they were wearing. Because they're designing for a global audience. Take, for example, the farmer emoji. clothing and accessories that they were wearing. Because they're designing for a global audience.
或者可能以另一种风格起舞，但它们都应该阐述同一个基本概念。最近，雷切尔·宾和谷歌的娱乐团队重新设计了安卓表情符号的整个库。对于所有不仅仅是没有躯干的脸部的表情符号，团队必须深入考虑它们所穿的所有服装和配饰。因为他们是在为全球受众进行设计。以农夫表情符号为例。服装和配饰。因为他们是在为全球受众进行设计。
Take for example the farmer emoji. Originally we had designed the farmer emoji, very American Gothic style. So, you know, a pitch fork and wearing overalls. But a lot of farmers all around the world, they don't actually use pitch forks. That's kind of an old and very American characterization. And also the overalls to some degree weren't necessarily the outfit that most farmers globally wear.
以农夫表情符号为例。最初我们设计农夫表情符号时，采用的是非常浓郁的美国哥特式风格。所以，你知道的，拿着干草叉，穿着背带裤。但全世界的许多农夫实际上并不使用干草叉。那是一种陈旧且非常美式的特征刻画。而且在某种程度上，背带裤也未必是全球大多数农夫穿的服装。
So we changed the actual prop that the farmer was holding into a grain, so to really put more emphasis on what's grown universally versus tools that may not be universally used. And this kind of global inclusivity is the same stuff they'll have to consider with the emoji that I proposed, you know, of the person meditating. What will it wear? Like, what's the color of the clothing? Is he or she are they going to be wearing leggings, a leotard, a t-shirt? You know, it's good that they're thinking about this, but Gings, Liattard, a T-shirt? You know, it's good that they're thinking about this, but the Google designers are never gonna really be able
所以我们将农夫手里拿的道具换成了一穗谷物，从而真正把重点放在全球普遍种植的作物上，而不是那些可能并非全球通用的工具上。而这种全球包容性与他们在我提议的那个表情符号——你知道的，冥想的人——上必须考虑的东西是一样的。它会穿什么？比如，衣服的颜色是什么？他或她、他们会穿着紧身裤、紧身衣（leotard）还是T恤？你知道的，他们能考虑到这一点很好，但是，紧身衣、紧身衣、T恤？你知道的，他们能考虑到这一点很好，但谷歌的设计师们永远不可能真正做到
to fairly represent all cultures. Right, and Unicode is this governing body with a bunch of representatives, but they're all mostly from these big tech companies. And so this whole system, it kind of irks people. This is not a good system. You shouldn't have to ask these people's permission. This is Keith Winston. I'm Keith Winston.
公平地代表所有文化。没错，统一码是一个拥有众多代表的管理机构，但他们大部分都来自这些大型科技公司。所以整个系统，它有点让人反感。这不是一个好系统。你不应该非得去征求这些人的许可。这是基思·温斯顿（Keith Winston）。我是基思·温斯顿。
I'm an assistant professor of computer science here at Stanford. And he says, you know, if there is not an emoji that represents you or your culture, Unicode's process for getting one is not exactly quick. So having to wait, you know, two or three years for it to end up in the standard, and that's a long time. It doesn't take quite that long anymore. It's closer to one or two years. But still, Winston points out that there are already platforms like Slack that let you
我是斯坦福大学计算机科学系的助理教授。他说，你知道的，如果没有一个表情符号能代表你或你的文化，那么统一码获取表情符号的流程绝对算不上快。所以不得不等待，你知道的，两三年才能最终纳入标准，这是一个很长的时间。现在已经不需要那么长时间了。接近一到两年。不过，温斯顿指出，现在已经有了像 Slack 这样的平台，它们允许你
take an image and make it emoji sized where you don't need to go through Unicode. Yeah, totally because Kurt Colestead on our staff he does this and he makes a little emoji for every episode and we share it when the episode comes out. And it's just a little picture. It's not really an emoji. Exactly. And so there is no special encoding process required to make them. This is a much simpler way of doing it rather than trying to cram everything into Unicode. And even though I think Winsdine gets at some really important criticisms, if we went to a system where we really just sent tiny pictures, then the thing that I really love about emojis would kind of be lost, which is that they've turned into this sort of
获取一张图片并将其调整为表情符号的大小，你根本不需要通过统一码。是的，完全是这样，因为我们员工库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）就会这么做，他为每一集节目制作一个小表情符号，当节目发布时我们就会分享它。这只是一张小图片。它并不是真正的表情符号。没错。所以制作它们不需要任何特殊的编码过程。这是一种比试图把所有东西都塞进统一码更简单的方法。尽管我认为温斯顿触及了一些非常重要的批评意见，但如果我们走向这样一个系统——我们真的只是发送微小的图片，那么我真正喜爱的关于表情符号的东西就会在某种程度上丢失了，那就是它们已经演变成了一种
universal standardized language of pictures. Like the idea that some stranger in Argentina and I are both sending a heart-eyes emoji to express love, I think there's something really cool about that. I mean, that is a nice quality to the nothing universal. So what happened with your meditating person? You must know him by now. So for a few days after my presentation, I still hadn't heard anything.
通用的、标准化的图片语言。比如，远在阿根廷的某个陌生人和我都在发送一个“爱心眼”表情符号来表达爱意，我认为这里面有些东西真的很酷。我的意思是，这对于无需语言的事物来说是一个很好的品质。那么你的冥想者的进展如何？你现在一定知道了。所以在我的演讲结束后的几天里，我仍然没有任何消息。
Like no email thanking me for my proposal or letting me know when I'd hear back or anything like that. It was just total radio silence. And then I was just scrolling on Twitter. So I just saw that emojipedia has tweeted about some of the new emoji. Let's see, I'm opening up the page.
比如没有电子邮件感谢我的提案，或者让我知道我什么时候能听到回音之类的。完全是一片死寂。然后我正刷着推特。然后我看到 Emojipedia 发推文谈到了一些新的表情符号。来看看，我正在打开页面。
Person with a beard, star eyes, zebra giraffe, a hijab emoji past, that's really cool. Not seen, wine. A serious face with symbols covering mouth, face with open mouth, vomiting, ooh, it's person in steamy room, person climbing, person in lotus position for yoga and meditation that's fine. Past. Alright, there we go. So that's it, yours passed.
带胡子的男人、星星眼、斑马、长颈鹿，头巾表情符号通过了，这太酷了。没看到，葡萄酒。嘴上盖着符号的严肃脸、张着嘴的脸、呕吐，哦，是蒸桑拿的人、攀岩的人、做瑜伽和冥想的莲花坐姿的人，这很好。通过了。好吧，就是这样。所以就这样，你的通过了。
More importantly, reuse passed, that's so great. Yeah, both of ours were accepted and I am super excited about it as you could probably tell. So they changed the name of mine from person meditating to person in lotus position, you know, Unicode really likes the specificity of these things. And as of now, we're recording in August of 2017. It's not on your phone just yet. But person in lotus position, the hijab emoji and all these new ones should be on your phone
更重要的是，里夫的通过了，这太棒了。是的，我们俩的都被接受了，正如你大概能看出的那样，我超级兴奋。所以他们把我的名字从“冥想的人”改成了“莲花坐姿的人”，你知道的，统一码真的很喜欢这些说法的具体性。截至目前，我们在2017年8月进行录音。它现在还不在你的手机上。但“莲花坐姿的人”、头巾表情符号以及所有这些新表情符号都应该会在今年年底前
by the end of the year. So when you get the person in lotus position emoji on your phone, you can think of Mark and how he doesn't even like yoga. No, but that's that's the thing. I actually have started doing yoga and meditation. It's one of the many things that came out of doing this story for me. A huge new appreciation of yoga and meditation. Well, that's remarkable. Well, then, Namaste for real, then. Namaste, Roman.
出现在你的手机上。所以当你手机上出现“莲花坐姿的人”表情符号时，你可以想到马克，以及他其实根本不喜欢瑜伽这件事。不，但这就是重点。我其实已经开始练习瑜伽和冥想了。这是我为这个故事进行采访所带来的众多收获之一。对瑜伽和冥想有了全新的巨大感激。嗯，这真了不起。好吧，那么，这下真的要说“Namaste”了。Namaste，罗曼。
You know that just means hello, right? Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha-ha- More emoji talk after these fine people pay for our listening experience. Raise hands. Our female dancing bunnies versus our male dancing bunnies, we made the decision that they're wearing the exact same outfit. Men get the skimpily a tar just like the ladies. Really gender a lot of it is a social construct and if we're trying to be more universal it's sometimes good to eliminate some of the social construct so it doesn't feel super resonant for one culture over another. Yeah also I just have to say that the men in dancing men with bunny ears is one of my favorite emojis at this point but me too. I love that we kept the man wearing a little a little theotard instead of putting shorts on him. That was one of the best moments in my career.
你知道那只是代表“你好”的意思对吧？哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈>在这些金主爸爸资助我们的听觉体验之后，还有更多关于表情符号的讨论。举手。我们的女性跳舞兔女郎与我们的男性跳舞兔女郎相比，我们决定他们穿一模一样的衣服。男士们和女士们一样穿着清凉的紧身衣。真的，很多性别认同是一种社会建构，如果我们试图变得更具普遍性，有时消除一些社会建构是很好的，这样它就不会对某一文化产生过于强烈的共鸣，而排斥其他文化。是的，我也不得不说，戴着兔耳朵跳舞的男性是我目前最喜欢的表情符号之一，我也是。我很高兴我们保留了让男人穿着小小的紧身衣而不是给他穿短裤的设计。这是我职业生涯中最好的时刻之一。
I'm kidding. But I do think it's great. I do think it's a great decision that we made. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Mark Bramhill with Katie Mingle and Avery Trouffleman, mixed in tech production by Sheree Fusef, music by breakmaster cylinder Melodium, Lollatone, and Sean Rihau. Our digital director is Kurt Colstead, the rest of the team includes Seleney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. The story was adapted from Mark's podcast Welcome to Macintosh, where he's currently airing a multi-part series on emoji. It goes a lot deeper than we could fit into these 25 minutes, so if there are things you're still wondering about, you know, emoji-related, they're probably
开玩笑的。但我确实觉得这很棒。我认为我们做出的这个决定非常棒。《99% Invisible》本周由马克·布兰希尔（Mark Bramhill）与凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）和艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）共同制作，由谢里·菲塞夫（Sheree Fusef）进行混音和技术制作，音乐由 breakmaster cylinder、Melodium、Lollatone 和肖恩·里豪（Sean Rihau）提供。我们的数字总监是库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead），团队其他成员包括塞勒尼·霍尔（Seleney Hall）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、泰伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。这个故事改编自马克的播客《欢迎来到麦金塔》（Welcome to Macintosh），他在那里目前正在播出关于表情符号的多集系列节目。它的深度远远超过了我们能塞进这25分钟的内容，所以如果你还有什么想知道的事情，你知道的，与表情符号相关的，可能
answered in this series. The first episode is out now. You can find it at Macintosh.fm or wherever you listen to podcasts. And the show has lots of other episodes about design and technology that you beautiful nerds are bound to enjoy. Go check it out. We commissioned original emoji art from Kara Rose DeFavio that tells the complete story of this episode entirely in emoji. You have to see it is at 99pi.org.
在这个系列节目中都能找到答案。第一集现在已经上线。你可以在 Macintosh.fm 或任何你听播客的地方找到它。这个节目还有很多关于设计和技术的其他剧集，你们这些美丽的极客们一定会喜欢。去看看吧。我们委托卡拉·罗斯·德法维奥（Kara Rose DeFavio）创作了原创表情符号艺术作品，完全用表情符号讲述了这一集的完整故事。你必须去 99pi.org 亲眼看一看。
And finally, thanks to Rishi Keshe her way for explaining to us on the Illusionist podcast, what Namaste actually means. I heard it. It's a joke. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% invisible is part of radio-topia from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative
最后，感谢瑞希·凯什·赫瓦伊（Rishi Keshe her way）在《诡辩家》（The Illusionist）播客中向我们解释了 Namaste 真正的含义。我听到了。这是个玩笑。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心广播街（Radio Row）制作。《99% Invisible》是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的一部分，这是一个汇聚了播客界最棒、最具创新性
shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by the Night Foundation and coin carrying listeners just like you. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Ork. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But our fabulous home on the internet with more design stories than we can ever tell you in audio form is our website at 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
节目的联盟。我们得到了奈特基金会（Knight Foundation）以及像你一样的硬币资助听众的支持。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上 @ 我，帐号是 Roman Mars，也可以 @ 本节目，帐号是 99PI Ork。我们也在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上。但我们在互联网上拥有更多设计故事的美妙家园——远远超过我们在音频形式中能告诉你的内容——是我们的网站 99PI.org。你 本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。